hello everyone this is Amir from audio science
review it's back to school time again this time on
a topic that may sound trivial but it actually has
fair amount of complexity underneath uh luckily
you can't learn it uh it's just
something that's not usually talked about
online and that is frequency response measurements
um you know you all probably know have heard of
the term and probably have some idea of what
it means the curves typically look like this
this recent jbl 4349 studio monitor that i tested
and it always has two axes one is the frequency
the frequency response and the vertical scale
varies depending depending on what we're showing
in this case is the spl or sound pressure that
the speaker is producing if we're measuring a dac
or amplifier that'll be the output voltage
typically but it really doesn't matter what this
is as long as you know we understand more or less
this is the output and this is the frequency and
and we look at how that output varies now in case
of amplifiers and things the frequency responds
often extremely smooth and flat and then he rolls
off at some point and we can judge that easily you
don't need to watch this video to learn that but
check out this frequency response we have a little
dip in here oops sorry you can't see my mouse uh
there's a little dip in here there's a little peak
in here then more or less is okay but we got these
little tiny wiggles then we have a little valley
in here then it goes up a little bit then we have
a broad area that's up here then we have some more
wiggles um a lot of people who really you know die
hard objectivists say well this is all i need and
i can tell you something sounds well my question
is what's you know what does this sound like
if it you know if you have two little shoulders
like this versus one does it make a difference
what if it's this wide what if it's less than this
peak but broad what difference does that make so
and that's the topic that i'm going to cover in
this video um on this which is how do we interpret
a frequency response measurement from a speaker
and headphone where it's never straightforward
just like the arrow that i've drawn and so you
need to have some skill in interpreting that um so
just let's bring up a headphone for example this
is a hi-fi man sundara that i recently reviewed
we look at the frequency response this part's easy
you say well okay there's less bass way down here
but what about this little wiggle over here is
that audible but this will go over here um then
we have this broad region which is just a little
bit below a target horrible is that versus these
then we have these peaks in here how horrible
are they this this valley in here this seems
very very large deviation correct so this must
surely be a lot more audible than something
like this or maybe even this right like this
area seems very minor compared to this massive
20 25 db changes in frequency response so clearly
we need to have some tools to understand this
i can guarantee you that if you use your lay
intuition it would be wrong uh on this thing
so to understand how we analyze these things we
have to look at psychoacoustics psychoacoustics
is a research of human hearing and tons of tons
of studies to be done in last 80 years or so on
you know how do we perceive sound uh millions
of tests with respect to frequency tonality
sounds going up and down what have you and this
is done both for medical purposes and also for
pleasure as far as you know music enjoyment and
so forth the key concept i want you to understand
in here which is a gnarly one for any lay person
to understand but stay with me and it's called
the auditory filter bandwidth and it's measured
in in what we call ERB equivalent rectangular
bandwidth our hearing system has a what we call
a filter bank a set of uh resonators that as the
sound uh agitates those points you know we pick up
basically amplifies that that that region and we
hear it and the shapes of those auditory filters
is actually not pretty it changes with frequency
and it has a complex shape but what is important
is that within that auditory filter bank's
bandwidth if you have a bunch of sounds tones
that are close together they essentially get
averaged by the year the ear can't distinguish
between them when they're within one filter bank
so imagine if i tell you numbers 1 to 100 but
you can only have 10 10 buckets in there 1 to 10
and then to 20 and and so forth so within those
buckets variations are not as important the ear
basically averages all the spectrum energy in
that filter bank now i warned you this would
be complex but um one simplification we have is
which is called the this ERB thing and you can
go to Wikipedia unfortunately this page doesn't
have any uh um graphs in here and and i should
have probably brought one up but we can simplify
the uh the auditory filters as being rectangular
as if you just go up like a you know pulse and we
say if the filter was rectangular how wide is it
and the width of that filter bank in your
hearing system widens as frequencies go up
what does it mean to widen that means you
have less discrimination which means that
more tones are averaged together and that's how
you hear them so if one frequency is higher and
one frequency is lower they get added up to
each other and average out as a total energy
the way that as i just explained there's a formula
in this uh Wikipedia that actually tells you you
can grossly simplify this but it's very useful
for this kind of analysis that we want to do
back in my envelope analysis and you can see
in here basically just depends on the frequency
and you plot that you get a graph that looks
like this basically this is 20 hertz at the
bottom sorry it's a small graph and it says
that at 20 hertz our auditory bandwidth is
only 25 hertz to 30 hertz so that means very
little very few frequencies are averaged that
means in the context of a speaker in a
room where the room activates magnifies
certain frequencies we actually care about a
very narrow analysis of of those frequencies
but look at what happens at 20 000 hertz at 20
000 hertz this thing shoots up to like 3 000 hertz
so a tone that's mulch of tones that are at 20
000 hertz they all get averaged within a three
kilohertz bandwidth um so what this means is that
as you go left to right in your frequency response
so from here on variations here are far more
audible because the hearing bandwidth this ERB
is very narrow which means very frequent very few
frequencies are added together to build the total
energy that your hearing system is going to
perceive whereas when you get up here you can
see these little wiggles your ERB is wider it's
a big chunk over here it's this wide so it will
average out these things so these little peaks
and the valleys on the right are never heard
whereas the same peaks and the valleys here are
audible so indeed this can be audible although you
know the level is so low here that personally
you know wouldn't bother with one or two db
corrections but if this was a little louder for
sure it's something that that would be audible um
and you can see the width of this guy is the same
as with these things but perceptually they're not
at all the same so let's take this example further
and this is an article by the way that i wrote
um for white screen review magazine a few years
ago and i'll put a link in the description
where it talks about this detail this has a lot
of applications both in just simple frequency
response measurements but also in in measuring
your room and acoustics in your room and if you
don't understand this you can really chase
your tail uh strongly so this is a actually
a measurement of a speaker i have in a room and at
high resolution basically no filtering and look at
what the frequency response in room looks like if
you've never done this is like whoa what is this
no way is this the frequency response
are we really hearing all this
wildness well obviously we're not hearing this
wireless and it's because of ERB but uh truly
this is what you get why do you get this because
direct sound comes to the microphone in here but
so does all the reflections from every surface
since they all have different delays they're
out of phase with each other and they mix up and
essentially make this random waveform that you see
in here every time a waveform gets delayed
enough to be out of phase it will actually
cancel resulting in these sharp drops and if
it's the other way around it will actually add so
it's a complex thing now a microphone is
we say it's a dumb thing microphone has no
psychoacoustics analysis and neither does a
simple measurement like this but your brain
and your hearing system does not hear this how
does it hear it you need to go and smooth that
smoothing means filtering this the ups and
downs equivalent to what your hearing system
perceives so if i'm interested in knowing what's
happening in high frequencies this one-third
octave filtering will give me that but in low
frequencies now it's lying to me it smoothed
out all this stuff saying there are no ups and
downs well that's false because there are clearly
ups and downs in here and one third of an octave
is way way too wide to show that so what you
really want to have is an adaptive filtering
where you filter very little at low frequencies
and you filter a lot at high frequencies
to get an idea of what is your room sound
if you will um an example of applying this uh is
when i reviewed the odyssey room eq and uh here
i'm measuring my own reversal onto speakers and
it's sort of a before and after correction that's
performed you can see how messy this this graph
is right this high resolution again but here
all these little peaks actually mean something
because they are audible the bandwidth in here
is well more than 10 or 20 hertz and here you want
to get a filter correct if it's at 14 no 14. if
it's at 35 hertz you want to put a filter at 35
hertz you want to find this exact peak in here
and put a 35 hertz and then you want
to adjust the width of the filter to be
only this wide you don't want to go past in here
because then it'll change this area so in low
frequencies up to about 100 200 hertz all of these
things are real and the peaks and valleys here
when you get up here this is all garbage because
this is not what you hear low frequencies what
you see is what you get high frequency what you
see is not what you hear and uh so to to see
what we perceive as just overall tonality
forgetting about as much about the ups and downs
i went ahead did the one-third octave filtering
and then all room equalization systems have
what is called a target response curve and this
is the preferred one with Audyssey you have to go
then Denon and Marantz have an app where to let
you edit that and that's what you want to have
this this stock one doesn't have this and and
screws things up but anyway it wants to achieve
this line but this line this target has no ups and
downs right so it is as filters and as smooth as
possible so we we got to get take our frequency
respond also and smooth it out also so we can see
where we stand relative to this target now by the
way this microphone i use is a crummy mark it was
the market i think came with AVR or something and
i don't have the calibration for it so you know it
droops down here ignore that but here we can see
that we're more or less tracking this target but
in here we had a big deviation and obviously went
ahead and and corrected that uh in here and then
excuse me you try to follow this curve until
you know we lost the calibration on this thing
so it's very important to uh pay attention
to you know the filtering that you use and
this is a feature this is roomy cube wizard that
lets you go in there and and filter the response
on this thing now let's go back to the original
43 949 speaker that i reviewed and i might do a
standalone video on this uh the biggest flaw
in here was that it actually two flaws one
was that there's a dip in here the crossover and
then there's also the twitter level is elevated
up here fortunately it has some dip switches which
i'm showing down here where you can take this
and knock it down and this would be quite audible
because it goes from 2 kilohertz all the way up to
maximum frequency of 10 kilos plus all of it
is elevated it's the classic thing of thinking
that more highs sell speakers better and and
they do so even though it's less accurate
um yeah they're in there so but a lot of
people were horrified of of this dip and
i was upset at it too because harmon tends to
parent company jbl it knows that this has to
be flat for the best sound so i went ahead and
listened to it and i dialed in an eq in there
and that's the equalization that i put in verse of
that it seems like a very large correction in here
right it's a 4 db and at 1500 hertz so this that's
a lot of boosting in here but i tell you the
effects are quite subtle it is not at all night
and day turning and turn it on and say wow listen
up now it was very subtle it was a good change
needed to have that eq in there um but it's very
subtle so here's an example of the eye deceiving
us and why is the eye deceiving us because the ERB
here is not this narrow in here is you're probably
getting the filter banks are averaging fair bit
let me go back to the original graph averaging
these fair bits so clearly we're not hearing
a big valley in here where we're hearing chunks
of it averaging here in chunks with average here
and so it's important to listen um a lot of people
are shocked when i say when it comes to uh room eq
and room sound reproduction your ears are you must
use your ears and because your ears and your brain
work together to tell you what you perceive
and you know single graph measurements can be
quite misleading so you got to have the skill
to either apply psychoacoustics manually like
i've been teaching you right now in this video
or go ahead and experiment with equalization so
take your current system bring up a
parametric eq it has to be a parametric eq
why because it has this q value at the
bottom that i've set to 2.5 and when
you set that q value that changes the how wide
the filter is how many frequencies it impacts
go ahead and take the same filter and put
it up at 10 kilohertz or eight kilohertz
and vary its shape you'll notice that if you
make it quite narrow where q is five or six
you'll turn it on and off it'll actually make no
difference you can make it like six or eight db
peaks or dips and you can turn it on and off you
know it'll be very subtle to no difference at all
why because again you're hearing filter bank
at high frequencies is very broad very lazy
and therefore if you make a correction in
the middle of it the little sliver in that
it doesn't change the total energy much and
if it doesn't change the total energy much
it's not an audible thing so for that reason i
i see a lot of people going out there and taking
making headphone measurements like this and they
come up with tons and tons of filters when i do my
equalizations you see very few filters even like
this one in here i put in here was very subtle
on this thing because again it's it's quite
narrow in here um i sometimes go ahead and
experiment by putting some other corrections in
here but there are differences next to zero people
who use a computer program generate these
filters the computer program just takes this uh
frequency response here and attempts to flatten
all of these things it will flatten this little
thing in here and flatten this it'll flatten this
it'll flatten that and all of a sudden you have
18 filters in there but if you go in there and
turn those filters on and off you'll notice
that many of them will not make a difference i
like this little thing in here two or three db
bandwidth is like 300 hertz this is just not
audible in the way it seems the other thing
is that these filters don't act in the way you
think they're they're shown in pretty graphs
like i have in here that this is what they
think they're gonna do but usually they have
some spillover effects and the actual response
isn't precisely this so that's another reason to
not do that um recently i was watching somebody's
video on on headphone tuning and uh uh this little
nine dollar Sony headphone i'd reviewed and i said
bad eq it makes sound good and i just put a few
filters in there he said it sounded terrible
with those filters but then he went and said
i created my own without measurements
and he wound up with 30 filters in there
my 30 filters there's no way with 30
filters you can have anything that's
that's resembling what cycle acoustics tells
you of course it's very easy to imagine that it
makes a change by the way you can put a filter on
there and think that you're reducing the highs and
your brain may say reducing the highs so a lot
of times there's this on off switch you can see
here i'll close my eyes and i'll turn it on and
off randomly where i don't know what state is in
then i'll switch it back and forth to make sure
that i'm not fooling myself into thinking that uh
the filter is making an effect or not and in fact
if if the effect is not large i'll leave it out
and i'll just show you the major ones and uh
usually if a product requires more than four or
five of these filters i i give up anyway it just
means the designer didn't do a good enough job in
in you know fixing all the flaws i
don't mind fixing one or two things or
with my preference in here having more bass boost
but not me becoming a designer on that thing
so bottom line is just be careful in looking
at frequency response measurements uh always
in your mind have a little uh psychoacoustic
simulator that says ah these are audible like
this little peak in here likely is audible
and then in this case it was a good thing
but it also gets combined with room modes so
that's another topic we'll talk about in the
future so this interpreting the low frequencies in
a loudspeaker is got its own complexities beyond
what i talked about but the foundation is what
i said the changes in frequency response earlier
matter more than later in frequencies and how wide
they are makes a bigger difference in audibility
than the narrow ones so these little wiggles in
here are just not audible because they you have
to get lucky for a musical note to just hit
that right there for it to be half a d louder
and with music having many tones you're just not
gonna hear that well something broad like this
yeah there's more chances of musical notes
hitting that so this this obviously is is audible
okay so hopefully you learned something uh and
if you already knew all these things then great
a number of people on the forum on ASR forum
know these things uh but i imagine most people
haven't been exposed to the full theory from
start to finish and i thought i'd do this video
see you in a future video bye